you have one or two kids now I have one
child yeah yeah he seems so happy with
he's cool he's a cool kid I like him
yeah though we're thinking about kids is
they don't there's no way to prepare you
for how much you will like the one that
you have because other people's kids
seem like a real pain in the ass this is
what why I keep you here I think yeah I
rely honestly I want one you should do
it do it right the reason why is because
when I see dudes like this right real
regular do you know just like talented
you know comic comedian guys well cause
I know and he can do it and and the
times I've seen him with his kid it
seems like fun you know tell me great
whenever I see you with my kid obviously
a game face I'm gonna keep it together
friends blow this for me you're done
yeah do you understand me yeah so
obviously we're putting on a game face
when we see you up to it is really fun
three well as I was on my way over here
tonight at 8:30 p.m. I was like who is
up this late ever right that doesn't
happen anymore get ready it's a big
difference
wait so [ __ ] like this I used to be
thrown out you sleep at 9:00 at night I
sleep like things really wind down at
our house by 10:00 it's very quiet now
this is really interesting
yes before you had a kid what was your
schedule like oh my god soups casual I
could also win the Prix kids I could
sleep basically like 11 hours a night
then I would take a 90-minute now yeah I
was just a human kitty cat one I was
talking to a girl friend of mine who
when I first moved to Los Angeles one
night we went to that restaurant the
stinking rose yeah as a joke we were
like [ __ ] it let's go to the stinking
rose you know why because we have
nothing to do
and I look at you guys with the three
dogs yeah it's god bless you I mean it's
it's really different like to mark like
what'swhat's the morning like you
probably have a gig in the evening or I
have a cable read at 1:00 at Warner
Brothers so what time you gonna pop I'll
probably leave the house at noon
yeah but what time you actually go to
bed I'll go to bed at 5:00 in the
morning see that's insane it's not it
but you also just had by the way I know
the responsible you had a sugar-free Red
Bull at the nine o'clock this is some
[ __ ] that's gonna change yeah I
think that I just from drinking Red Bull
[Music]
you're about the same age as Stephen
young 25 years I've just been sleeping a
5:00 in the morning right it will to
shoot some is all crust Oh it'll make
you a better person well just not as
happy yeah so I mean you'll be yeah
you'll be like having an amazing time
but you'll be doing a lot of dumb stuff
that you don't want to all right it'll
be mostly just standing around at
people's birthday parties for the rest
of your life all right
[Laughter]
[Music]
krylon and they remind you of you right
and then occasionally they do something
cool and neat then sometimes they're
just a dick yeah usually it's pretty
cool and maybe you have to admit though
like when you're when you work out of
town yeah you come back home oh it's on
the house daddy your son is excited to
see you I'm guessing you and your wife
have stable genetics Bobby and I we are
a hundred percent producing some type of
serial killer or psychopath well have
you it's on both sides okay family like
family gathering stabbings uh-huh they
happen at family gathering okay so the
kid's gonna be an alpha of some kind
yeah it's not gonna be
they're not gonna be a weak child boy or
girl well it skips a generation
okay that's what I heard stabbing
they're gonna cut it did skip us because
we're relative oh yeah so it's gonna go
to our kids right this it's really not
the only thing that go to your kids is
all the weird [ __ ] that you can't help
that you do around them yeah you gotta
be careful yeah yeah
sarcasm is really dangerous right kids
will say almost anything you say right
back to them Wow
and I want to BRE with you babe because
um romantic you did say the breed which
was really good
but I want to procreate with you babe
because sexier
you're right you're bright kids are
pretty fun they actually are pretty fun
and by the way perfect if you don't
really sleep that much now it's perfect
because you find that you'll be up at
9:00 it's really weird but it's like
kind of fun it's like a free drug that
you are on that makes you cry it keeps
you awake yeah so you cry and it keeps
you awake and then you feel shitty Oh in
the first couple of years you also eat
stuff you don't want to eat because
you're endlessly at somebody's [ __ ]
birthday parties literally there's these
like pizzas oh my god get ready bro once
you start school yeah you got to keep in
mind so there's like preschool and then
you have all the preschool friends and
then you move on to grade school then
there's grade school friends [ __ ]
you're just on a birthday rotation oh my
you just keep a bin of like weird
presents like you do have to go unless
sometimes you really have a lot of
writing you got to do right or you're
very sick those are the only real
options
well you're generally you're working out
of town yeah obviously yeah yeah exactly
but you had your face done but when
you're working out of town you got to
act like you're sad because like all
right if you're up in Vancouver for like
a couple weeks like making a movie yeah
yeah and then people are like people
call you from LA on FaceTime you gotta
be like the worst day in my life up here
literally is probably the worst day like
what'd you do I was like well we had a
scene in the name it was done
everything but it was just it's hell
it's never probably coming out yeah yeah
Wow that's a great thing when you're on
the road well if I have a kid I'm gonna
happen when I'm a cop you know I'm gonna
be with I'm gonna hang out with you for
a bit you're gonna give me notes yeah
and I'll know all the rules you know the
other thing about being a parent saying
it isn't also not really that hard
everything that you need to know reveals
itself immediately yeah yeah like oh
don't let them fall off the thing yeah
safety things right no just reveals
itself don't leave your pills right have
you done that yes for the dogs or dogs
your benadryl no was unisom wait the
fact that if a cat had overdosed on
benadryl I don't know if that's irony
the cat took too much our G medicine is
full-blown insanity that's a that's like
a human centipede yeah yeah it took one
of my kittens at the time you don't know
just don't leave drugs generally around
rule around right or too loose at all
but I feel like even you didn't know
that as a grownup man
yeah yeah
[Music]